a 7 años de intervención militar saudita
en yemen es lo que denunciaron los miles
de personas que marcharon este sábado en
la capital yemení saná la coalición
liderada por arabia saudita intervino en
marzo de 2015 después de que los hutíes
expulsaron al gobierno respaldado por
esa misma coalición alameda durante
siete años hemos enfrentado la brutal
agresión contra nuestro país hoy
conmemoramos la firmeza yemení la
legendaria firmeza que el pueblo yemení
logró contra las fuerzas de la
arrogancia observar estas
manifestaciones tuvieron lugar un día
después de varios ataques sutiles en
suelo saudita uno de ellos provocando el
incendio de una instalación petrolera
enreda a tan sólo 20 kilómetros del
circuito de fórmula uno del gran premio
que está previsto para este domingo los
organizadores decidieron mantener el
evento afirmando que la seguridad está
garantizada el reino árabe respondió
este sábado con ataques aéreos en la
capital yemení dejando ocho muertos
hutíes el mismo día los hutíes
anunciaron una tregua de tres días y
propusieron intercambio de prisioneros
y anunciamos unilateralmente la
suspensión de los ataques con misiles y
drones y todas las acciones militares
hacia el reino de arabia saudita por
tierra mar y aire durante un período de
tres días afirmamos nuestra disposición
a convertir esta declaración en un
compromiso definitivo firme y permanente
si el reino de arabia saudita anuncia y
se compromete a poner fin al asedio y a
detener sus incursiones aéreas en el
territorio de la república de yemen de
una vez por todas al mam la gente solo
día- pena el gestar el conflicto ya ha
dejado decenas de miles de muertos y ha
llevado a yemen al borde de la hambruna